hallo
herzlich willkommen in meine trocken
welt heute haben wir hier richtig tolles
wetter ich glaube dass sommer kommt
jetzt endlich so langsam und bei diesem
tollen wetter darf natürlich ein
leckeres und leichtestes er nicht fehlen
dies ist es er habe ich euch bereits
letztes jahr in meinem blog vorgestellt
ich glaube es haben aber nicht alle
gesehen deswegen möchte ich jetzt noch
einmal als video veröffentlichen weil
ich euch auch einfach zeigen möchte wie
schnell und wie einfach
dieses rezept geht und ihr solltet es
wirklich unbedingt ausprobieren das ist
so neckar also ich kann eigentlich
niemanden der dieses rezept nicht mag
der az habe ich jetzt auch drei
portionen runtergerechnet
ihr könnt das rezept natürlich auch
verdreifachen vervielfachen
wie ihr möchtet es eignet sich nämlich
auch ganz gut alles party gericht gerade
muss man in so einer großen schüssel
anrichtet aber jetzt zeige ich euch erst
einmal die zutaten für drei personen und
sag ich später noch einmal einiges dazu
ich werde heute drei portionen zu
bereiten dafür nehme ich mir drei hohe
gläser in die werd ichs schichten und
dafür braucht ihr 50 gbc das sieht so
aus kammern fertig kaufen
ich hoffe da immer diese hier die gibt's
bei uns beim globus versteht auch
mehrere drauf oder pc gibt es eigentlich
in jedem supermarkt zu kaufen
ihr braucht 125 gramm tiefgekühlte
früchte ich nehme am liebsten himbeeren
und dann braucht ihr noch 125 gramm
schlagzeile die sollte kalt sein und zum
verfeinern nehme ich ganz gern amaretto
oder himbeergeist wenn man kinder mit
essen oder gar kein alkohol mag nimmt
einfach traubensaft johannes besser haft
oder irgendeinen saft thema grad da hat
die sahne habe ich jetzt mal ihren hohes
gefäß gegeben die muss ich nämlich
gleich schnell
die wird es ganz einfach steif
geschlagen
bei sammeln müsst ihr aufpassen dass sie
nicht sie nicht überschlag das heißt
wenig denn das gefäß umkippt darf sie
nicht raus fließen
die sahne stelle ich kurz in den
kühlschrank und kümmere mich so lange um
den beetzsee den müsst ihr nämlich
nehmen und einfach grob in stücke teilen
also wirklich nur ganz grob so dass man
später dann auch noch ein stückchen
nochmal zurück dann habe ich es gleich
einfacher und übersichtlicher
das war das einzige prinzip schon jetzt
wird nämlich dass er geschichte zuerst
kommt jetzt die hälfte das bis in die
gläser oder sagen wir mal ein drittel
das hammer höhere schichten machen
drücken
denn wenn es gleich schmeckt es sowieso
unter dann gebt ihr da ein paar tropfen
saft oder eben wie kermit rein und dann
kommt da noch sagen
die gläser ganz sauber imst am eschen
spritzbeutel dann kommt wieder
geschichte
dann die restlichen früchte aufteilen
und ihr könnt gerade wenn ihr mit
amaretto arbeitet da auch gern ein paar
am martini mit reis geben das schlecht
auch richtig und dann noch die restliche
sahne noch mal ein stück besser
obendrauf geben und dann noch mit mit
pfefferminze dekorieren
mainz ist fertig und steht im
kühlschrank
das geheimnis darin liegt jetzt dass
dieses er noch etwas durch zieht also in
so kleinen gläsern würde ich mal sagen
so eine halbe bis dreiviertel stunde
dann sollte es gegessen werden weil es
dann einfach so ist dass die himbeeren
an trauen und die sahne fängt dann an
etwas zu gefrieren die website cult und
der pc nimmt dann die feuchtigkeit aus
der saane und aus den himbeeren an wird
etwas weich auch dann trotzdem noch ein
bisschen bis fest das heißt ihr habt
dann nach einer dreiviertelstunde nicht
eine komplett durchgereichte masse
sondern als es so ich wirklich der
zeitpunkt dass ich sagt so schmeckt ist
es sei richtig gut
falls ihr dieses ist er aber in einer
großen schale anrichten wollte es geht
natürlich auch so mache ich zum beispiel
wenn ich viele gäste hat und wenn sich
dann jeder einfach rausnehmen kann so
viel wie er möchte
dann gebe ich das ganze in ein großes
gefäß weil dieser drei stationen menge
würde ich jetzt sagen könnt ihr es dann
eine stunde lang ziehen lassen
bei der doppelten menge mache ich es
dann aber so dass ich es mir dass uns
zwei stunden ziehen das weil dann die
himbeeren eben nicht mehr gefroren sind
und schon etwas angetaut sind probiert
dieses rezept auf jeden fall aus ich
würde mich freuen
ich freue mich auch über euer feedback
und freue mich schon aufs nächste video
und bis 1